[Music]
and do it for the grab news submitted by
felix from the east the gritty story
from the bronx shown in the new york and
then the new joker [ __ ] stay away from
the bronx shown in the new yorker movies
attracting hordes of influencers is
there gonna be any spoilers i haven't
watched it yet it's impossible why don't
you take a break and one person go why
don't you go at 8 p.m. dude when you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] just take the kid no one
minds kids in the movie I said just take
the kid no mines kids and rated R movies
and I'm pretty sure he's not old enough
to recognize what's happening you guys
movies home all the time early in the
morning when no one's there yeah
nobody'll be there no 10 a.m. I'm trying
to enjoy the movie earliest I'm trying
to enjoy the movie though I'm not trying
to babysit I'm trying to get him yeah he
will cry his brains out and then cause
it rough I can babysit you said it hurry
Oh drop the drop now I get two miles
that I can watch it that's a solution
just gotta be free I've been wanting to
talk about it immediately after I
watched it but I [ __ ] didn't say
shush nobody's trying to watch it like
every week I listened I watched it but I
was too drunk to remember it we've been
trying to schedule Joker flight three
for weeks now I drink a lot during that
video let's say the stairs are [ __ ]
iconic yeah did you watch it yeah what'd
you think what'd you think of it was bad
you know I get it was just at the end
one day after he I didn't know you
thought that it is actually that we're
just trying to find this and that
forever you don't like it what happened
no what's going on you didn't like the
Joker I [ __ ] hated that stupid movie
keep doing well okay so these stairs
that we're talking about here
there are these stairs that are in this
oh I love that picture that's a dope
shot yeah so this is a very iconic scene
at the end of the movie after he am I
gonna give you spoilers but its iconic
do you like to dance on them thank you
Oh dancing thank you for something so
now people are flocking to these stairs
and trying to recreate this scene with
the same kind of dance specially since
Halloween - yeah exactly so there's all
these people going
take him she looked like Michael Jackson
a little bit that's cool
and then even people are not dressed up
it was just a whole bunch of that's a
dope photo even a video kind of dark
though when you think about why he's
doing that yeah I can't no no they so a
lot of the locals are upset because you
catch me well they are just trying to
get by neither stairs they need the
stairs who can wear the function exactly
for the function of them being stairs
and so it's even gotten to the point
where people are tweeting out things
like it's really called The Joker stairs
on Google now I just searched it please
if you're reading this and you're not
from around here
or ever been to the Bronx new Yankee
Stadium does not count please do not
come here thanks Bronx red yes that's
what we say about [ __ ] people coming
to out late but listen they got a good
reason they got a good reason cuz this
next one says why people gonna travel to
the Bronx on them stairs like the Joker
and end up getting robbed I love it
then stairs ain't nothing but an asthma
attack and a swift robbery set up you
know welcome to the South Bronx
so people are are warning like locals
are warning tourists like don't [ __ ]
come here you're gonna get rocked I
would have set up a hotdog stand right
there are the robbers let's just kick it
there how do your gonna get robbed find
that place before that though before you
hear someone that recognized it
they're apparently they're really
there's common mr. famous room you can
find anything famous for like the Bronx
area like South Bronx like those stairs
were already known for being there so
it's already been a landmark laughing
yeah actually because you know um how
what's-her-name AOC
what's her full name Alexandra possio
Cortez so she grew up in that area she
was just saying like the Bronx is much
safer now and I'm happy to say that but
she says that she'd be happier if
tourists didn't take their selfie sticks
to her home borough
I think the way a lot of us feel is
listen like keep your Instagram posts
outside of the boogie down like this is
for us you can't do that though it's not
your exactly it doesn't work like yeah
you don't own [ __ ] it's America and I
own all of it and people are gonna just
want to go more yeah yeah but she's also
saying like growing up she knew to
always avoid that area cuz it's very
high yeah why don't they do that and
increase security and [ __ ] maybe make
the crime go away [ __ ] Manson murders
brother after the Tarantino movie came
out everyone's going to every single
site yeah like and they're taking
pictures of where the Manson murders
everyone should [ __ ] bust out a hot
dog stand where all these locations are
we're in comic-con there were 30 hot
dogs fans and they were all making money
on every [ __ ] quarter capitalizing
and I'm like why don't the locals do
that they're not business people like
you don't think that's what I'm saying
hot dog stands all the way yeah I get it
it is [ __ ] annoying but I also get
annoyed at people that are like we own
this is ours get out I'm from there so
therefore I speak for everyone there you
can't man your menu fine oh we can do
that already to a little bit like we're
like dude get out of La I mean for me
it's a joke like I don't really need it
you walk that get out of La I'm serious
check it out [ __ ] traffic and I get
like I don't usually get upset because
of traffic but sometimes our [ __ ]
drivers that get me up saying I'm like
get the [ __ ] out of LA what religion do
you ascribe to that you don't get upset
in traffic
Oh cuz I just understand traffic spin
happen but when people are [ __ ] in
traffic that's what gets me upset yeah
true muscles get me upset for sure I'm
in traffic and I'm [ __ ] yelling at
all times at all times I'm very angry in
her I thought you were level-headed I've
been here forever man I've been here at
Benelli forever and I've been in so much
[ __ ] goddamn traffic that I can't
hang with it anymore
I'm like that long enough where you
subscribe to the channel yeah they
should subscribe to the channel that's
something that they should do right now
maybe traffic will go away wait did you
move here you're not even unit you're a
transplant yeah where you from been here
forever I'm just haven't been here for
13 years now who has the right to say
this is my area anyway no one does yeah
no one does only the Mexicans and Native
Americans they don't even get it right
because they provide with somebody
else's before them yeah before them yeah
probably like some guy covered in leaves
what was that that the dinosaurs the
dinosaurs are those like what do you
call that that the second mass
extinction that happened on the Ice Age
people actually give it back to the leaf
people I'm down with that they're not
around to clean so the less the earliest
people are still here but what if you
like legally lost a war that's true of
your point we should definitely
definitely gotta remember that too I
think the point of this story is like
[ __ ] social media people man like I
think that's what it is [ __ ] them on
both the angles cuz there's the people
who taking the picture in the steps and
they're people bitching about it on
social media [ __ ] both of them yeah what
I don't understand is okay why aren't we
allowed to take pictures anywhere in
this country right you can that's why
people why would people not like that
because they find it annoying because
it's it's intrusive on their life dude
it's like Abbey Road I've said this
before on the show I'll say it again
Abbey Road in Great Britain there's a
there's a [ __ ] web site right now you
can go to Abbey Road live and see a live
feed of [ __ ] standing in the middle
of the street trying to retake the
[ __ ] photo yeah and I'm not even
kidding you do it right at 1:00 at all
hours you can see these [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] and people being there
the night
at all hours and people honk gonna be
like get the [ __ ] out of the road I love
it I love the local I wouldn't even take
that road then right but I think
sometimes there's just some roads you
got to take the matter what it's like
the [ __ ] 405 if you're a local
shouldn't you just take some pole for
that and yeah the [ __ ] right I'm like
Lombard Street like everyone always like
those poor people that live there but
you know I'm like why would you live
they chose to live there they probably
inherited it cuz I'm like if we have
every right if they have every right to
come over here I have every right to
gentrify where they moved out of so if
they're like coming in here from
whatever Milwaukee I'm like okay well
[ __ ] it I'll move into your old
neighborhood then I'm helping you well
if if it gets popular okay okay you
gotta wait yeah you gotta wait it's like
I don't want people here right so
they're like then go to Detroit words
like secluded as [ __ ] right and I go
there I'll be like I'm gonna go back to
LA actually on second thought it is it
is awesome that's why everyone wants to
move here I'm trying to load this camera
I'm trying to see that oh yeah camera
the internet it's [ __ ] funny man not
great because they have audio too so
sometimes you can hear people yelling ah
oh really
if you're there now what time is it
right now over there no like 4 a.m. oh
just kidding I don't know well they
probably want to take it during the
daytime let me see what time is it
12:50 a.m. it's not late I want to do
Torah [ __ ] like even if millions of
people did the same [ __ ] I still want to
do tour is [ __ ] me too I love it I had
the [ __ ] lady power top pizza
everyone doing that [ __ ] I want to do it
but like what well like fail at it yeah
did you see that thing I posted I think
yesterday it's like a little girl so
that the tower piece is this way I love
it know if you have you guys been did
you see it no gigs out I did the one at
Universal CityWalk everyone like [ __ ]
like let's thriller it looks ridiculous
everyone there I'm like I've refused to
do the pose I'm just gonna smile and
like having behind it but then your
picture ends up being all boring no we
did something else I forgot what it was
but what you do you would you do
cool-kid would you do the pie flop no oh
yeah we probably did but everyone's
literally looking like the thriller
[ __ ] music video it's insane it's
funny
instead yours is like you and Casey like
yeah can you imagine one that musics
playing you're fighting with your camera
and people are in the background going
dude and you're like [ __ ] you
you didn't [ __ ] bring the code when I
told you - wow that was specific I like
to be very original with those pictures
I like to pretend it's my penis you know
no one no one else would see that I
actually do what do you know what I've
always thought I would do that nobody's
ever done is is lick it like it's a
penis Oh we'll deal
I'll show you let me see so you go like
that but then you stick the tongue like
that very curious oh yeah then I'm gonna
open my real big so people get Photoshop
dicks into it I don't think so I'm not
that dumb
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]